Windows that generate electricity by directing light to solar cells.
Lightweight, high-powered batteries that aren't built but are grown.
That was neat stuff.
Engineering viruses to create batteries.
More efficient lighting systems that rely on nanotechnology.
Innovative engineering that will make it possible for offshore wind power plants to deliver electricity...
...even when the air is still.
And it's a reminder that all of you are heirs to a legacy of innovation,...
...not just here but across America.
Countries on every corner of this Earth now recognize that energy supplies...
...are growing scarcer.
Energy demands are growing larger, and rising energy use...
...imperils the planet we will leave to future generations.
That's why the world is now engaged in a peaceful competition...
...to determine the technologies that will power the 21st century.
From China to India, from Japan to Germany,...
...nations everywhere are racing to develop new ways to produce and use energy.
The nation that wins this competition will be the nation that leads the global economy.
I am convinced of that...
...and I want America to be that nation. It's that simple.